[Musique]
la nouvelle plage de l'est cherche son
identité mais on sait déjà ce qu'elle ne
sera pas gelée d'ici là c'est pas le
beach club pointe calumet
pas de foule en transe à prévoir dans ce
secteur du bout de l'île mais pas de
baignade non plus c'est sûr partout des
panneaux indiquent que le sol sous l'eau
est contaminée
c'est une contamination qui a été fait à
cause de la marina sylvie bibeau fait
partie de ceux qui portent ce projet de
plage depuis plus de 15 ans quand la
marina beaudoin a fermé à quand une eau
baignable selon m pour moi le d'élèves
2-1 et raisonnable à moins qu'on trouve
des artefacts la sape est intrigant ce
ne serait pas le premier retard dans le
projet car en 2013
on disait déjà la plage devraient être
prêtes l'été prochain après des dépenses
de 1 million 400 mille dollars
finalement elle a coûté pour l'instant
près de 9 millions et 5 millions
supplémentaires sont budgétés pour la
décontamination
on a fait pas accès à l'eau mais il ya
quand même des jeux d'eau a dévalé bar
de plage on peut louer des embarcations
comme ces kayak simple ou double qui
seront disponibles dès vendredi et enfin
ce parcours avec les guides on peut
aussi informer les gens qui viennent
avec leur propre embarcation sur les
trajets qui sont intéressants plairait
aux et peuvent s'arrêter une grande
jetée en bois permet aussi de surplomber
le fleuve en face de l'île
sainte-thérèse
quant à la navette fluviale qui reprend
du service entre pointe aux trembles et
le vieux port
elle s'arrête un peu plus de deux
kilomètres en amont de la plage et si
vous vous demandez pourquoi ce n'est pas
une plage de sable blanc bien c'est
parce que le sable risquerait d'être
engloutis totalement par le fleuve en
cas d'inondation contrairement aux
petits cailloux qui ont l'avantagé de
rappeler la plage de nice à valérie
plantes
si mathieu prost radio canada montréal